hi guys doug mercado here and welcome to
my cleaned up
man cave well in fortune fire i'm often
introduced as a kali martial artist or
edge impact weapon specialist but i'm
also a knife designer today i want to
share with you the different knife
designs i have out there as well as my
collaborations let's do this
so my first journey into knife designing
was with k-bar knives over here it was
during a time when i was doing some
training with the forest recon marines
from both the philippines and the us
marines the philippine forest recon were
carrying this knife it's basically a
design taken from the us marines mark ii
k-bar knife except a bigger blade that's
not a knife that's a knife but in
working with them we got to make this
which we call the k bar big brother
fittingly they know me as kuya dog kuya
means big brother now this blade right
here you see on the top right there with
the painting of it that was a workhorse
from season one of fortune fire where
jay nielsen stabbed it to a car doors
which survived jay nielsen's blade test
so that's at least the cool thing about
this k-bar big brother design
[Music]
the next plate we have here is the mk
ultra that's a design by jason knight
now jason and i talked about creating a
blade for production that is of his
famous design here now i have my own
kukri blade here now by the gurkhas when
they're using this are made famous by
them it's got a nice weight for chopping
it's got that curved blade but it's also
got a thicker spine so it's very forward
heavy jason knight's design is a lot
lighter it's still got the thickness so
it got that curve to cut and slash it's
great for thrusting but simply
redesigning the handle which moves
filipino blades that are curved gives
you good retention at the same time you
can do some nice chopping work with just
the flick of the wrist but it is much
lighter having the false edges to cut on
the backward on the backward swing and
use it as a true survival butt fighting
knife we call it the mk ultra because
jason was kitschy about it i don't know
what the empty ultra was but in the end
i found out also that the mk stands for
maikai the knight not the cia version
now
[Music]
if you had
the cookery we also decided to make a
nice
folder version which is also the
mk folder version which is a nice kukri
folder for those who enjoy something
that you can have and carry around as
opposed to this big survival knife right
here
now the blade underneath the kukri is
the cortada with russian blades now the
cortada actually is tied into the time
with the k-bar big brother because when
i was training with the force recon
marines the philippine recon marines
were carrying this which is their
version of a genuine thing meaning a
half a scissor blade now it has the same
design for the idea that if it's curved
in it's going to slash and cut inward
the only thing that i did with the
cortada was i wanted a more pronounced
and more acute tip right there so that
it's more acute that i can cut with that
it's got the same curve down there for
cutting but also for thrusting as you're
doing that of course the design you have
there is a version of my tattoo that i
also carry around with me
going down the pipeline we also have the
cortada dagger which is a smaller
version to carry that it's basically a
genuine dagger with the same idea it's
got the same features it's curved got
that curved handler for retention for
slashing also it's got that acute point
for thrusting cutting and thrusting
now we come into my tactical bleed
[Music]
[Applause]
designs my first venture in tactical
blades was the dark knife with fox
knives now the dart means direct action
response tonto direct action response
means to have a tactical folder that
opens up with simply a catch which is
the emerson catch so let's say it
catches in the clothing with one flick
of the wrist it catches and deploys so
that's the beauty of this now it's got
the retention ring like a karambit but
it's also straight blade so that you can
use it this way as a straight blade for
whatever use you have as an everyday
carried blade
right beside the dart
are the mako blades the original maco
and the mako version too mako being the
shark style blade this is the start of
my collaboration with bastinelli knife
designs now we wanted to have a karambit
style retention ring but a different
blade design where the dart was straight
blade the mako still has the catch right
there that you would catch to open it
but when you hold on to it it's like a
true claw of nature where it claws in
and you can control that where a
straight blade would be a different
angle and the karambit would face
outward the marker design is this way
now if you're going to hold it in this
way it's almost like those persian
blades where it's got a curved slashing
and cutting blade this is my first
design with bassinelli knives
so when is the blade not a blade when
it's a rescue tool so right beside the
mako are the mk tools mark ida kali
rescue tools and the difference here is
that idea of having that retention ring
that you have here this is the one with
the case over here if you want to have
that or you can just put a clip on this
now the beauty of this is that it's not
a full ring where you're not allowed to
have rings in some places it's got a
carabiner so after use you can just clip
it to whatever you want it to be but at
the same time you got your seat belt
cutter right there you can also use it
for uh you know wrenching for oxygen
tools and everything else and this is
the fixed version we also have the
folder version of that same thing it's
designed from the dart but at the same
time there are no blades to it you see
this is a phillips screw head that you
can use also for deployment that opens
up into your edge right there what you
have here is phillips flat it's got a
flathead screwdriver it's got a seat
belt cutter still got your oxygen tool
opening and hexagon things to open up
and the ring at the same time is not a
full ring it is a carabiner for
retention if you need to put it away so
when is a karambit not a karambit
folding blade when it's arrested
the next design that you have here right
beside that are the dm talon you got the
folder and the fixed blade my first kind
of caramel blade with 511 tactical first
the fixed one is when is a blade so much
lighter it's when you have it
skeletonized here where you can see
right through that and you can see that
the design like a talon it's not curved
like a claw but sharp like a talon it's
much lighter here so when you look at it
this way it truly is like when you move
with the blade it's just part of your
hand you don't feel the weight of the
blade at all now
came up with a folder because some
people don't like to carry fix for the
folder version it also has the catcher
so that you can also do a one-handed
opening
and rounding up the last over here is
actually also on the first one the black
version of it is on the first of the
blades is the d-max helps with the max
venom and the d-max to me was the first
design we talked about with the max
venom collaboration was to have
something like a neck knife something
that's flat that can keep us a neck
knife but at the same time when you
deploy it it's easier to just deploy and
fit in the hand nicely it's not a very
thick wide blade but a smaller blade as
a karambit even when you're using it in
this particular
motion it's quite light but at the same
time tactical and the first kind of neck
knife idea for a karambit blade to have
now in the bottom is another of my fixed
blades with bastinelli knives when i met
with him i talked about a very earlier
time when i actually had a broken pair
of scissors my first broken scissor was
a blade i played with so we decided to
come up with the lip decor which is like
your very flat line kind of blade a
broken pair of scissors what i love
about it is that it's so flat it doesn't
imprint when you keep it around your
body it's a nice
version of also a broken scissor more
like a scapula
this is actually a whole set of the four
aces the second ace in the hole that we
got right there is the pika karambit now
i wanted to create the karambit back to
what it originally was a very small
hooked blade right there that is curved
in its use the pikachu rabbit idea we
both came up with was to go back to
something that's very small to carry
around something's very light and just
has a small hook almost like a little
punch dagger with a hook right there
now the third ace of the hole that we
got with bussinelli knives is the spade
now the speed right here is because the
tip is like the spade and once again
we're talking with the four aces we
wanted a little robust blade it's a
little bit thicker than the decor and
the pica but at the same time has a
serrated edge there so it's a heavier
blade if you want serrations you can use
it to cut and use some heavy duty work
with it
well guys there you have it these are
victorian designs i have out there
hopefully it gave you a bit of insight
why they're created it's not just about
creating a blade it's also the why why
was it created what's the story behind
it from hay bar knives to jason night
knives to bastille creations to max
venom to fox types and russian blades
now 511 tactical i hope you enjoyed the
little presentation here and see you
soon on the forge
you